hey what's up everyone things have been
a bit crazy around here with the vlogs
as you know Carmichael's gone kind of
the end of the year everyone's finishing
up our final few projects we had a brand
deal we were gonna do that was supposed
to go up today but ended up being
delayed so instead I'm just gonna you
know what are you up to man there's been
a whole lot of talk about what's the
best
it's not gonna be jerky the corridor
rival that I made is easily the best
nerf gun on the planet I did this paint
job on it I'm pretty proud of it what
else is going on we're still gonna be
releasing two videos before the end of
the year I won't say what they are too
late that's already been in we also are
one step away from finishing the digital
commercial that I was working on it's
for almost strike digital commercial you
might hate the game but it was a lot of
fun to make the commercial and so it was
still really cool experience you're
gonna take two weeks off kick my feet up
drink a peppermint bourbon hot cocoa
just one though just one be responsible
let's go see what Sam's up to hey Sam
what you up to everything dark Santa
then didn't assembly and I'm just gonna
go through and good idea
you gotta find its true path those B I
gotta find what this video is supposed
to be and turn it into that I'll leave
you to it let's go follow your heart
okay so it was in the air for 1860
frames at 240 frames per second divide
that almost eight seconds how many miles
per hour is 38 meters per second we shot
it straight up on that second one it was
going 85 miles an hour what are you
talking about here an upcoming vlog
video where we shot something at 85
miles an hour oh and it may or may not
have a GoPro in it are you working on
anything else today possibly I think we
may have just gotten notes on we need to
add more stuff to this mobile strike
strike oh no why are you stressing out
right I'm not stressed enough I'm just
saying those yeah we didn't include the
cars in this shot this is kind of what
we deal with a lot working for clients
we should yeah so it's just drop adding
the Humvees well they want to have more
explosions yeah say no cuz we've sent
them four drafts and they've extended
the deadline
student Mauro they're just bringing this
up now let's go see what Spencer and
Nico are up to Spencer's teaching me
about the server I'm learning about how
it works so that if we want to start
using it for all our stuff I'm not just
like an old grandpa yelling at
technology for the distance good luck
hey Ben hey how's it going good man just
checking in with everyone's cue up dude
Brent's starting a nerf overwatch sound
today he likes to take his time with
things so I'm waiting for him to can I
get gone oh it's like the mail it's like
you know that the post office is gonna
deliver it at some point you just don't
know kind of when or where yeah like if
maybe yesterday yesterday I told you
this and now you travel you try to sell
on camera like it's your camera did you
say it on camera I said it I said to you
things that I've gone through in my life
I was giving you indicator of what not
to do don't only have a beard don't not
have a moustache I think you guys need
some time apart
what are you up to today Obi I'm just
being a cute puppy just being a cute
puppy man he loves being on camera so my
wife Jenna she made everyone in the
office a whole bunch of baked goods not
only that she's like she wrapped it up I
almost don't want to open this there's a
sample some cherry cheesecake muffins
you got some white chocolate peppermint
bark
we got fudge we got the gingerbread man
we got poor-man's toffee it's all
delicious
all delicious yeah she bakes like all
day yesterday
he's a pleasure in that picture me barks
oh honey it surprised me you like that
son anyway guys so that's what's
happening today we're gonna be putting
out videos for another actually what
like two weeks okay you're still gonna
be getting salmon eco videos yours might
see like one or two really like random
videos uploads in the salmon eco Channel
so more stuff to watch yeah and then
we'll be back in what second week of
January cool and back to our every other
day season to do coming at you have a
wonderful birthday every birthday wait
no it's not your birthday have a
wonderful holiday season
have a wonderful December 20th to
January 3rd happy early Hanukkah